[Music]
in the previous video we saw basics of
trigonometry in this video we will see
some of the applications of trigonometry
in real-life trigonometry has lots of
applications in the real world and can
be used in many practical situations
around us they are mostly used in
finding the heights of things such as
towers buildings or they are also used
to find the distance between two things
how do we find these Heights and
distances using trigonometry let us see
that with the help of an example but
first let's talk of one more important
thing before I put a question on the
screen we have seen trigonometric ratios
of angles of a right angle triangle
hence forming the right triangle from
the given question is the most important
step while solving problems now I will
put a question on the screen and you try
to sketch out a right triangle from the
given information let's start with a
simple example read the question
carefully and try to form a right
triangle here we are given a wall you
can't represent the wall with a vertical
line like we have done here you don't
really need to draw an actual wall now
it's obvious that this wall makes an
angle of 90 degrees with the ground
surface that's something we can
definitely assume we are also given the
height of the wall as 20 meters a ladder
is inclined against the wall like this
again you can represent the ladder with
the inclined line just like we've done
here what else are we given we are told
that the angle made by the ladder with
the surface is 30 degrees that is this
angle is 30 degrees and finally we are
asked to find this length that is the
distance between the foot of ladder and
the bottom of the ball now some of you
may be wondering if we could have drawn
the ladder on the other side like this
guess what it will not make any
difference at all so we will take the
one we've done originally
so here we have our right triangle which
pertains to this problem it was easy to
form wasn't it let us name its vertices
as a B and C okay let us solve this
quickly now we are given the measure of
angle C here and we are also given the
length of its opposite side a B we are
asked to find length of BC which
trigonometric ratios we will use here
sine cos or tan BC is the sine adjacent
to angle C and that's what we're
interested in now let's understand this
well length of BC is what we want and
the length of a B is what we have there
opposite and adjacent sides of angle C
what does this tell us it tells us that
we should use that trigonometric ratio
of angle C which involves opposite and
adjacent sides what will be that ratio
it will either be tan or caught because
these two involves both opposite and
adjacent sides of an angle let's go with
Dan here we see that tan C is a B over B
C now all we need to do is substitute
the given parameters what does Stan of
30 degrees if we remember from this
table tan 30 is 1 over root 3 we get 1
over root 3 equal to 20 over BC solving
this further we get BC as 20 times root
3 don't forget the unit here which is
meters so the distance between the foot
of the ladder and the bottom of the wall
is 20 root 3 meters you would have got
the same answer if you have used cut
instead of tan as well we will leave it
as an assignment for you to verify that
in the next video we will look at
another example see you there
[Music]
you